[Music]
silicone
oil and lots of toil these were the
ingredients chosen to create the perfect
new rubber but James Wright accidentally
added an extra ingredient to the
concoction foreign
[Music]
using its Ultra superpowers of
bounciness stretchiness and silliness
putty has dedicated its life to fighting
boredom and the forces of evil
what molds into silly animals and silly
shapes Silly Putty unless you grew up
under a rock Silly Putty was part of
your childhood but did you know that the
insanely addictive toy was actually
created by Scottish inventor James
Wright as a rubber substitute during
World War II nothing else a silly putty
James Wright's employer General Electric
marketed bouncing Putty for not very
silly things at all like hand exercises
and leveling wobbly Furniture
but clever marketer Peter Hodgson
spotted its fun potential as a
children's toy and changed his name to
Silly Putty
at Easter he sold the putty in a plastic
egg clever huh the egg stuck and it's
still sold in this iconic packaging
today always put your silly putty back
in its egg or run slowly away then he
turned to a newfangled technology the
television fighting off competition from
the likes of Mr Potato Head
and the hula hoop buy yours today at all
toy drug and department stores get one
get two get more so why is Silly Putty
so damn fun stretchier than rubber
I'm bouncier too
300 million units sold since the 1950s
[Music]
Bass
Silly Putty the silliest toy around
[Music]